(pages turning)
- Lovely sweater.
- Thank you, this
one's belongs to me.
- This sweater, now, these are.
- Sweater?
- Sweater, sweater.
- This is something that
we, that you, that you got?
- This is gonna go ahead and
start here and then go up.
- This is very nice.
- Is that your sweater?
- Sweater?
- This is a sweater.
- I like a cardigan.
- Do you love how the
line is like this?
(men groan)
- Sweater.
- Thanks, it's lambs.
- And what are these,
actually made of?
- Oh, I think these
are just made out of
harder parts of sweaters.
- Sweater, sweater.
- Sweater!
- Thank you, it's a sweater.
- I stole this!
- Your sweater's mine.
- It's mine.
- It looks stolen.
- (sighs) Sweater?
- Amazing pop art sweater.
- Sweater.
- Yeah, makes you look like
you have fat shoulders.
- One, two, three, four,
and then a double six.
It's very good.
(pages turning)
(vibrant classical music)